bonjour à tous nous vous proposons cet
après-midi d'écouter une partie de
l'examen du projet de loi sur l'égalité
femmes hommes
un texte qui a été examiné et voté au
sénat la semaine dernière lors de
l'examen en séance le gouvernement a
déposé un amendement sur le complément
de mode de garde amendement qui a été
adopté objectif aider les foyers les
plus modestes à faire garder leurs
enfants
cette mesure devrait bénéficier à 140
mille familles voilà tout de suite
direction l'hémicycle après l'article 6
juste saisi de deux amendements
discussion commune le 115 rectifié bis
c'est vous mêmes journaux qui le
présentaient
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
encore un amendement à visiterez
pratique est très simple qui concerne en
fait le versement du complément de libre
choix du mode de garde comme vous le
savez aujourd'hui les personnes doivent
en fait avancer et payer l'assistante
maternelle et ensuite elles sont
remboursées par l'organisme débiteur
principalement la caf du complément de
libre choix du mode de garder cette
avance de frais pour certaines familles
modestes et bien évidemment une
difficulté supplémentaire donc la maman
qui en réalité reprend une proposition
de loi qui avait été déposé par mon
collègue député jean christophe lagarde
reprend le principe d'une
expérimentation de du paiement direct en
fait de ce complément de libre choix
auprès de l'assistante maternelle ce qui
évitera aux familles d'en faire l'avant
ce que cette expérimentation soit limité
à des personnes qui sont soit en retour
à l'emploi sont en insertion donc on a
limité effectivement le champ de cette
expérimentation est que les assistantes
maternelles concernés soit en
sous-activité ou volontaire et
l'amendement 191 rectifié du
gouvernement
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
effectivement on peut je pense trouver
un consensus sur cet amendement du
gouvernement qui fait suite à une
réflexion qui avaient déjà été engagés
l'an dernier dans le cadre du plfss et
qui soulignait aulas difficultés
spécifiques des familles modestes à
pouvoir accéder à un mode de garde
quels qu'ils soient et en effet ce on le
constate dans les chiffres puisque dans
les familles les plus modestes
près de 90% des enfants sont gardés par
les mères de famille ça n'est pas
toujours forcément un choix c'est
quelque chose qui éloigne les femmes de
l'emploi et c'est quelque chose aussi
qui est profondément inégalitaire pour
les enfants qui ne peuvent pas avoir
accès un mode de garde quel qu'il soit
nous avions donc décidé d'instaurer ce
principe du tiers payant du complément
du mode de garde
le conseil constitutionnel a rejeté
cette disposition comme estimant ne
devant pas faire partie d'un document
comme le plfss
et je tiens à remercier najat
vallaud-belkacem de pouvoir
effectivement l'introduire dans cette
loi sur l'égalité femmes hommes pour
effectivement faciliter l'accès en
particulier donc aux modes de garde des
assistantes maternelles pour les
familles les plus modestes
c'est dans ce sens que madame jouanno a
déposé un amendement
nous nous avons à mener une réflexion
qui nous conduit à élargir le champ des
familles qui pourraient bénéficier de ce
tiers payant en considérant que pour une
un couple deux enfants le plafond
pourrait être celui de 24000 euros et
pour un couple avec un enfant
le plafond fixé à 21 milles euros
cela permet de d'accroître le nombre de
familles qui sont susceptibles de
bénéficier de ce complément de mode de
garde sous forme de tiers payant qui est
déterminant pour que des familles ne
grève pas leur budget et puisse avoir
accès à l'assistante maternelle
cela aurait aussi pour bénéfice de
sécuriser les assistantes maternelles
qui quelquefois peuvent être dans
l'hésitation contenu 2d faibles revenus
de ces familles et au travers de cet
amendement c'est une façon d'aider les
familles modestes d'aider le recours aux
assistantes maternelles et de sécuriser
les emplois des assistantes maternelles
c'est pourquoi évidemment je vous invite
à voter cet amendement car c'est un
grand signe donné en direction du
développement des modes de garde pour
les familles les plus modestes
merci donc à vis de la commission sur ce
deux amendements oui monsieur le
président mesdames les ministres donc
ces deux amendements qui diffère
légèrement dans leur rédaction
cependant comme madame la ministre elle
d'expliquer l'avant demande du
gouvernement a une portée plus large et
concernera plus de famille donc tous et
les deux amendements propose la mise en
place d'une expérimentation consiste à
inverser le tiers payant directement à
l'assistante maternelle on avait abordé
au moment du plfss 2013 et la commission
des affaires sociales lors de son examen
avait accueilli très favorablement cette
expérimentation
donc le but il est bien de faciliter
l'accès des familles les plus modestes à
un mode de garde individuel et on sait
que le choix des modes de garde varie
fortement selon le niveau de vie et
niveau de vie des parents donc pour les
familles les plus modestes l'effort
financier est deux fois plus important
lorsqu'il s'agit d'un mode de garde
individuel plutôt qu'un mode de garde
collectif donc on insiste encore et
toujours sur la nécessité d'ouvrir des
crèches et des modes d'accueil pour
l'enfant de manière en crèche ou en
structure collective
ceci dit pour en revenir à la vie avis
favorable à l'amendement
en 191 d'où vient d'être présentée par
le gouvernement et considérant qu'il
peut être satisfait demande de retrait
par là la vie de madame jouanno et je
souligne qu en accord avec le président
de la commission des lois
je souhaiterais au nom de la commission
des affaires sociales que l'amendement
191 soient vus avant l'amendement 75
merci même rapporteur selon l'article 44
alinéa 6 du règlement
la proposition de la commission du droit
sauf opposition du gouvernement
c'est plus gouvernement ne s'y oppose
pas donc a priori tu es donc donné donc
ses 291 rectifié qui sera soumis quelles
explications de vote de même genou oui
monsieur le président madame mesdames
les ministres
je crois que vous pouvez aussi remercié
comme moi jean christophe lagarde
d'avoir rédigé cette proposition de loi
puisque nos deux amendements sont
rédigées presque exactement pareil si ce
n'est un élargissement des bénéficiaires
et par conséquent bien évidemment nous
ne pouvons qu'y être favorable ça va
dans le bon sens et donc je retire mon
amendement mais encore une fois je pense
qu'il faut avoir l'honnêteté de rendre à
jean christophe lagarde
la paternité de cet amendement je veux
même pas ce que oui merci monsieur le
président un site c'est une mesure qui
effectivement on avait pu on avait eu
l'occasion d'évoquer déjà au pdf ss dans
les débats du ps est ce l'année dernière
il est regrettable que la mesure a été
retoquée par le conseil constitutionnel
qui ce qui a empêché l'expérimentation
de se mettre en place dès 1er janvier de
cette année je pense que c'est une
mesure intéressante tant pour les
familles que pour les assistants
maternels
j'alerte cependant la ministre sur la
charge de travail supplémentaire que ça
va occasionner pour des salariés des caf
qui sont déjà dans des situations
difficiles et quand on a eu aussi
l'occasion d'évoquer au travers de
débats depuis le ps poursuit au travers
de débats sur la situation des caf en
france
un autre point aussi plutôt un
questionnement sur le 3 2 de la maman je
me pose la question de savoir comment va
se passer
la déclaration ou la mise en place de ce
prêt pénales dans les cas d'urgence ou
les périodes de très courte durée
est-ce qu'il va falloir que l'assistant
maternel ou le foyer se déclare avant
d'avoir ce besoin de gardes ponctuelles
donc s'agit d'un besoin ponctuel bien je
met donc qu'on voit cet amendement 191
rectifiée présentée par le gouvernement
qui a reçu un avis favorable la
commission ceux qui sont favorables bien
levez la main ceux qui sont défavorables
il est donc adoptée et 75 rectifié beast
tombe après l'article si je suis saisi
d'un moment 14 rectifié qui prend pas un
bout du bras l'objectif de cet
amendement est d'éclairer la
représentation nationale sur la façon
dont le dispositif emplois d'avenir
s'inscrit dans la politique d'égalité
professionnelle
il propose qu'un bilan soit remis par le
gouvernement analysant c'est quand ces
contrats
d'un point de vue quantitatif en
examinant la répartition du nombre de
contrats entre les candidats des deux
sexes et au plan qualitatif en nous
indiquant dans quelle mesure ils ont
contribué à la lutte contre les
stéréotypes professionnels
cet amendement reprend la recommandation
numéro 15 de la délégation merci invite
de la commission oui la délégation a
fait pas mal de recommandations 36 je
pensais certaines ont été traduites en
amendement donc il me semble que le
rapport annuel d'évaluation que le
gouvernement doit déjà remettre au
parlement
en application de l'article 5 de la loi
du 26 octobre 2012 qui créent les
emplois d'avenir le prévoit déjà
donc c'est une demande de retrait sinon
un avis défavorable à vis du
gouvernement de la ministre
la sénatrice mener tout dit puisque en
effet dès la mise en place d emplois
d'avenir le gouvernement a souhaité leur
assigner l'objectif d'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes et la mixité et de
fait je suis en mesure de vous donner
une information quantitative
intéressantes sur ce sujet puisque
sachez que l'on enregistre 50,6 % de
filles dans les cinquante mille emplois
d'avenir qui ont été conclus déjà cantal
informations qualitatives cette fois ci
sur le type d'emploi etc
nous allons la voir prochainement mais
je trouve que le chiffre est déjà assez
intéressant et donc au bénéfice de cette
explication je vous demande de bien
vouloir retirer votre amendement
l'amendement est retirée avant l'article
cette justice est un amendement 101
rectifié qu'il présente sont rectifiées
même meunier mais des menus qu'il
présente
madame meunier en tant que membre plus
en tant que rapporteur
il
alors
donc sur l'amendement 101 on est bien
d'accord
voilà donc toutes situations de violence
comporte un danger potentiel
il convient de permettre l'accès à une
mesure de protection à toute femme
victimes de ces violences et cette
disposition aura aussi pour conséquence
de protéger le foyer d'hébergement la
structure d'accueil d'accusation pour
obstruction aux droits des pères avis de
la commission des lois que cette fois
sur le plan rédactionnel même si on peut
partager l'objectif de vouloir protéger
les foyers d'accueil sur le plan
rédactionnel il ne semble pas que
l'objet soit atteint d'une part d'autre
part toute situation de violence
nécessite certes des mesures de
protection mais pas forcément
l'ordonance de protection qui a quand
même des contraintes aussi par rapport à
l'auteur des violences qui privatives
d'un certain nombre de droits pour
l'auteur des violences
donc ils ne sont pas opportun de
commencer à entrer dans une espèce
d'automaticité de leur donnant ce de
protection qui a livré un petit peu ses
effets et il faut laisser le juge malgré
tout gérer ce genre de problème pour
toutes ces raisons la commission a émis
un avis défavorable
merci à vis du gouvernement madame la
sénatrice j'avoue ne pas bien mesuré la
portée de l'amendement que vous avez
proposé qui ne paraît pas modifier
l'état du droit et en tout cas ne pas
répondre au voeu que vous exprimer à
savoir celui d'une efficacité renforcée
dans l'axé les femmes à à la mesure de
protection
cette efficacité en force et je propose
que nous y parvenions par précisément la
réforme de l'ordonnancé de protection je
vous ai proposé avec la réduction des
délais d'ouverture de l'ordonance avec
la possibilité d'avoir des audiences
séparées avec l'allongement des effets
de l' ordonnance de protection à six
mois je pense que c'est la meilleure
protection que nous puissions introduire
voilà donc je vous demande de bien
vouloir retirer cet amendement sinon j'y
suis défavorable
madame bourthoumieux je suis sûrement
fait mal comprendre en fin de compte je
voulais aussi porté l'aspect sur
l'important c'est le grand danger qui
est pour les femmes qui sortent qui sont
soumises à l'emprise de leur conjoint
mais je reformule ray donc je le retire
momentanément l'âge de retiennent 106
madame à l'article 7
deux membres de parole monsieur roland
courteau merci monsieur le président
l'ordonnancé de protection lordose de
protection est une mesure centrale de la
loi du 9 juillet 2010 elle vise se
substituant au référé violence à fournir
un cadre d'un simple aux personnes
victimes de violences
la permettant de stabiliser leur
situation juridique
j'insiste pour dire que la gamme des
mesures à la disposition du juge est
bien plus large
dans le cadre de l' ordonnance de
protection que dans le cadre d'une
procédure pénale ou et d'un contrôle
judiciaire
l'ordre de protection a fait ses preuves
est jugée positivement par les
associations la situation juridique dans
la victime est mieux assurée
malheureusement malheureusement on
enregistre une forte disparité dans sa
délivrance entre les territoires
bien utilisé dans certains départements
elle ne l'est pas ou si peu dans
d'autres pourquoi problème de preuve
désistement de la rue cayrade
le défaut de connaissance du dispositif
et des mesures qui peuvent figurer dans
leurs relances de protection défaut de
formation des magistrats des avocats
je ne sais pas
il est vrai que l'attribution de
pouvoirs pénaux au juge aux affaires
familiales nécessite comme le souligne
danielle bousquet et guy geoffroy dans
le rapport une véritable révolution
culturelle de la part hors comme cela a
été dit il suffit qu'un seul maillon de
la chaîne fasse défaut pour que tout le
dispositif soit stoppée en effet si les
avocats connaissent mal la procédure ou
si les magistrats la sous-estiment alors
les victimes à seront de fait souvent
écartée cela dit
reste le problème des délais de
délivrance ils sont extrêmement longs à
moyenne or nous sommes là en présence
souvent de personnes en grand danger
pour lesquelles il importe de réagir en
urgence et pas 21 jours ou 26 jours plus
tard
l'objectif de l'ordonance le semble-t-il
consiste à mettre à l'abri la victime le
plus vite possible afin qu'elles ne
soient pas exposés à des représailles
notamment avec des délais trop longs
nous ratons l'objectif
or parfois les victimes sont en danger
de mort certes je comprends qu'on ne
puisse pas d'élever leur glace en 24
heures ou même quarante huit heures il
faut évidemment tenir compte des droits
de la partie défenderesse et d'un
certain nombre d'autres contraintes
certes se pose également le problème des
délais de convocation
pourquoi ne pas généraliser la
convocation via huissier de justice
comme c'est le cas au tj de bobigny
plutôt que de persister a convoqué les
parties par lettre recommandée avec
accusé de réception c'est qu'ils
génèrent un délai de 15 jours et
contribuer à l'allongement totale du
délai de délivrance de l'ordonance en
fait réduire fortement ce délai est une
impérieuse nécessité
quant à la durée de 4 mois de cette
ordonnance de protection
toutes les associations concernées vous
diront qu'elle était insuffisante et ne
permet pas dans les faits d' assurer la
stabilisation juridique de la victime
trop souvent les questions relatives à
la séparation comme celle concernant le
logement où les enfants n'ont pas été
réglés
dans le délai de quatre mois par
ailleurs si cette durée pouvait être
prolongée pour les couples mariés
dans le cas d'une requête en séparation
de corps ou d'un divorce
par contre cette prolongation ne pouvait
avoir lieu
dans le cas de couples pacsés ou en
concubinage je me réjouis donc que les
délais de délivrance de l'ordonnancé
puisse être ramenés aux alentours me
direz-vous dans la ministre d'une
semaine et que la durée de l'ordonance
fois prolongé jusqu'à six mois
je proposerai un amendement dans le but
de permettre au juge aux affaires
familiales de démontrer plus rapidement
la réalité des violences en ayant la
possibilité de demander au procureur de
la république de diligenter une enquête
rapide sur la personnalité de l'auteur
des violences
l'objectif est d'éviter aux juges aux
affaires familiales de passer à côté
d'une situation pour le moins
préoccupante
j'en proposerai un second permettant la
saisine du jaf aux fins de délivrance du
nord glace de protection non seulement
pour des faits de violence du conjoint
ou du partenaire mais aussi pour des
faits de violence sur les enfants
je vous remercie madame cécile cukierman
de la parole chers collègues je vais
rejoindre a bien évidemment les propos
de notre collègue l'extension du
mécanisme de l'ordonance de protection
est à saluer en ce qu'elle met les
femmes victimes de violence en sécurité
dans la tente d'une instruction
malheureusement ce dispositif n'est pas
accessible aux femmes victimes de viol
en dehors du couple alors qu'ils
pourraient se révéler utile dans de
nombreux cas plus largement je tiens ici
à souligner les problèmes récurrents
auxquels font face les victimes de viol
dans le traitement leur plainte
outre l'impossibilité d'accéder à une
ordonnance de protection l'instruction
de cas de viol peut être
particulièrement douloureuse pour les
victimes et je souhaite vivement voir la
législation ont évolué à ce sujet le
premier sujet bien sûr concerne la quasi
systématique correctionnalisation des
viols ces crimes sont trop souvent
requalifiés en agression sexuelle est
une solution juridique à ce problème
doit être retrouvés dans les plus brefs
délais en envisageant par exemple un
aménagement de la charge de la preuve ou
une redéfinition pénale du viol cela
passe aussi par un nécessaire
désengorgement des cours d'assises qui
mettent des années à se prononcer sur
ces crimes rendre justice pour les
victimes est un élément fondamental du
processus de reconstruction et cette
problématique doit être adressée avec le
plus grand sérieux
par ailleurs lors d'un procès pour viol
ou agression sexuelle certains droits
doivent être garantis à la plaignante
en particulier il doit être clairement
établi qu'aucun magistrat ne pourra
questionner la victime sur sa sexualité
ces pratiques sexuelles ou plus
généralement comme on l'entend encore
sur sa moralité il faut aussi porter une
attention particulière à ce que le juge
ne demande pas de procédure qu'ils
puissent approfondir inutilement le
traumatisme de la victime en demandant
par exemple des reconstitution des faits
des expertises psychologiques ou en
multipliant les confrontation avec
l'agresseur la protection et
l'accompagnement des victimes de viols
ou d'agressions sexuelles est un sujet
réel qui n'est pas traitée dans cette
loi qui repose principalement sur
l'action du gouvernement
nous espérons donc une réflexion pour
être mené sur ce sujet en partenariat
avec les associations de défense des
victimes
les organisations féministes afin
d'aboutir prochainement à des solutions
mais madame la ministre vous avez évoqué
certainement quelques pistes dans votre
intervention général je crois que tout
cas nous souhaitons vous puissiez
apporter des premiers éléments de
réponse à nos interrogations en pensant
évidemment ses victimes merci nos juges
saisis de l'amendement 81,18 rectifié
qu'il présente ses goûts madame meunier
donc il s'agit de remplacer les mots
meilleurs délais par délai d'un mois
on sait la violence à l'égard des femmes
notamment dans le cadre conjugal et
familial doivent compte tenu de leur
ampleur et de leur importance en termes
de conséquences humaines mais aussi en
termes de conséquences financières être
placée au premier rang des priorités des
tribunaux les récents bilans de
l'ordonance de protection montre bien
combien cette mesure a été mise en
oeuvre de façon
ce parent disparate selon les tribunaux
de grande instance il y à une
cartographie tout à fait différente en
france et ce n'est pas acceptable on ne
doit pas craindre non plus un
encombrement des tribunaux
les femmes sont responsables et on le
doit pouvoir leur donner accès à la au
dépôt de plainte et les plaintes doivent
être prises en compte dès leur première
dès le premier dépôt nous devons donc
donné une force à ce texte qui déjà est
très important mais prévenir les risques
de violences graves voire de crimes
c'est une chose est à mon avis la
première mesure est de traiter
rapidement donc le délai maximal
s'entend bien sûr dans un mois il faut
une réponse rapide adapter certains
tribunaux peuvent faire mieux mais on ne
sait bien que dans d'autres ce n'est
loin d'être le cas
donc pour donner cette priorité pénal il
m'a semblé important de mettre un délai
dans le temps deux commissions la
commission bien évidemment partage de
cet objectif de réduire le plus possible
les délais
sur cette ordonnance de protection
néanmoins la loi a parfois ceux-ci de
contraignant que quand on l'écrit selon
la façon dont on l'écrit on peut aboutir
à la verse de ce que l'on souhaite et la
inscrire un délai de 1 mois dans la loi
nous semble effectivement préjudiciable
au contraire l'objectif recherché
d'abord parce que vous l'avez souligné
au tgi de bobigny par exemple les délais
sont plutôt d'une dizaine de jours que
de un mois donc il faudrait pas donner
l'impression à l'heure où on veut que
tout le monde n'accélère que finalement
on a le temps et que un mois c'est
satisfaisant
donc c'est une première première raison
une deuxième raison beaucoup plus
juridique
tiens tu as que si le délai de 1 mois
était dépassé la loi est la loi il y
aurait des risques d'annulation de
procédure parce que le délai serait
dépassé et ça on ne pourra pas y
échapper ce sera le rôle des avocats de
la partie défenderesse que de
s'engouffrer dans la brèche
enfin dernière raison pour laquelle la
commission vous l'avez compris a émis un
avis défavorable c'est que la
responsabilité de l'état pourrait se
retrouver engagés
si le délai était dépassé alors que ce
n'est pas de son fait donc nous on
préfère au niveau de la commission la
vie y était défavorable sachant que on
compte beaucoup plus et là on sait qu'on
a le soutien du gouvernement sur des
circulaires sur le travail souligné à
l'instant par notre collègue roland
courteau
de faire prendre connaissance de ce qui
se fait de bien sur le sujet notamment à
la collaboration par exemple avec des
huissiers à bobigny est plutôt de faire
connaître et de répandre ses bonnes
pratiques que d'inscrire un délai d'un
mois qui nous sommes une fois plus
dangereuse la loi donc à mon avis
défavorable merci madame le ministre
mes arguments seront les mêmes que
celles de la sénatrice de la rapporteure
pendant virginie klès au fond nous
poursuivons exactement le même objectif
l'efficacité et la célérité de du
prononcé de l'ordonance de protection
pour compléter ce qu'a dit virginie klès
sachez que en moyenne la durée de
traitement d'une requête des ordonnances
de protection et de trois semaines alors
c'est vrai qu'elle a évoqués bobigny qui
est particulièrement exemplaire et dans
lequel on peut aller jusqu'à une semaine
mais moi je préfère que nous disions
clairement dans ces débats au sénat que
notre souhait c'est d'atteindre les une
semaine dans l'immense majorité des cas
plutôt que de nous fixer en effet un
délai maximal qui va inciter à prendre
le temps de remplir ce délai maximal
donc le gouvernement n'est pas favorable
à ce type de précision en revanche je
redis que nous poursuivons exactement
les mêmes objectifs et que la meilleure
façon d'atteindre le délai le plus court
possible
c'est précisément de s'inspirer des
départements où ça marche c'est à dire
de construire et nous le faisons un
partenariat solide entre le tribunal les
associations les collectivités locales
les huissiers de justice que vous
évoquez et ça vous voyez bien que c'est
dans la pratique que nous arrivons à
réduire ce délai plutôt que par une
mesure trop rigide qui pourrait être
contre-productive autant merci monsieur
le président j'entends les arguments ce
que donc je vais retirer mon amendement
mais donc avec toute l'attention et la
vigilance qu'il faut pour réagir vite
sur des questions d'urgence
je suis un moment 87 c'est vous monsieur
courteau poésie oui monsieur le
président henri convient de rappeler
qu'en de nombreux cas les enfants eux
mêmes sont les victimes de violences
conjugales
on sait que
très souvent entre 60 et 70% des cas les
enfants sont témoins des violences
conjugales ce qui ad'ailleurs de graves
conséquences sur leur psychisme et leur
développement mais de surcroît ces mêmes
enfants sont parfois eux mêmes
directement ou indirectement mais
surtout directement victimes de ces
mêmes violences avec là aussi de très
graves conséquences est donc cet
amendement a pour objet de permettre la
saisine du juge aux affaires familiales
aux fins de délivrance d'une ordonnance
de protection non seulement pour des
faits de violence sur le conjoint mais
également pour des faits de violence sur
les enfants au sein de la famille de
commissions même caisse
là encore la commission partage
complètement l'objectif du sénateur
courteau
simplement par souci de parallélisme
avec la rédaction de l'article 515 tiré
neuf et parce que les enfants qui sont
en danger ne sont pas forcément ceux de
la victime
l'avis est favorable sous réserve d'une
petite modification rédactionnelle qui
vous a été soumise je crois qu'ils
diraient la victime ou un ou plusieurs
enfants sont exposés et non pas la
victime ou ses enfants
ça peut être les enfants notamment du
conjoint vous êtes d'accord
oui monsieur le président tout à fait
d'abord pour rectifier la main demain ce
sens
d'accord donc l'amendement prendre
numéro maintenant 87 rectifier mais le
ministre votre avis sur 87 rectifier oui
monsieur le sénateur courteau
le gouvernement est favorable à voter
avec un prix favorable à votre
amendement avec la rectifications
proposées par la rapporteure je voudrais
simplement compléter le propos en
soulignant tout de même que le procureur
une fois informé des faits de violences
sur l'enfant que les enfants peut
toujours demander à ce que soit ordonné
des mesures d'assistance éducative qui
sont prévues par ailleurs à l'article
375 du code civil voire prendre lui-même
immédiatement une ordonnance de
placement provisoire
il faut que l'ensemble de ces options
apparaissent bien
là encore dans nos discussions pour pas
qu'elle s'excluent les unes des autres
mais je suis favorable à votre
amendement explications de vote
je n'en vois pas donc je vais mettre aux
voix cet amendement 87 rectifié qui a
reçu donc un avis favorable de la
commission et du gouvernement ceux qui
sont favorables bien levé la main ceux
qui sont défavorables
il est adopté un amendement numéro 15
rectifié madame continuera oui monsieur
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues le principe de
l'éviction du conjoint violent hors du
domicile conjugal a été posée dès 2005
au plan pénal cette compétence ensuite
été étendue au juge des affaires
familiales par la loi du 9 juillet 2010
quand il statue dans le cadre d'une
ordonnance de protection
c'est un principe auquel la délégation
aux droits des femmes attachent une
grande importance car l'éviction du
conjoint violent peut contribuer à
inverser le rapport des forces
symbolique entre la victime et l'auteur
des violences
à ce titre elle peut favoriser chez ce
dernier une prise de conscience
salutaire pour la victime
le maintien dans les lieux peut en outre
répondre à son désir de ne pas perturber
le cadre de vie des enfants en les
changeant d'école ou encore à son
attachement à son quartier à ses
relations de voisinage pour autant nos
auditions n'ont confirmé cette
disposition peine à entrer dans les
faits cela peut tenir à la volonté de la
victime de rompre avec un cadre
d'heuliez d'un cadre liés à des
souvenirs douloureux et de redémarrer
une vie nouvelle
cette volonté doit évidemment être
respectée mais ces freins peuvent tenir
à d'autres facteurs
les auditions auxquelles j'ai procédé
ont montré par exemple que le fait pour
la victime de violence d'avoir quitté le
domicile commun est d'avoir bénéficié
d'un hébergement d'urgence au moment du
dépôt de sa requête avait pu en pratique
incité certains juges à privilégier le
maintien dans les lieux du conjoint
violent
il serait choquant que le fait d'avoir
dû dans l'urgence et sous la menace d'un
danger imminent quitté le domicile
ils commun puisse invalidé le droit de
la victime à rester dans les lieux le
présent amendement apporte une
traduction législative à la
recommandation 18 de notre délégation
qui a souhaité lever toute ambiguïté en
ce domaine il faut que le principe de
l'éviction du conjoint du conjoint
violent continue à prévaloir même si la
victime a bénéficié d'un hébergement
d'urgence
merci à vis de la collusion alors la
commission des lois qui tente toujours
d'avoir le regard le plus précis
possible sur l'écriture de la loi a émis
un avis défavorable
cet avis est motivée par le fait que le
texte qui aujourd'hui dit le juge peut
préciser lequel reste dans le logement
et sauf circonstances particulières
c'est la victime
et là on y rajoute même si elle a
bénéficié d'un logement d'urgence
on est donc en train de compliquer un
petit peu le raisonnement et on s'expose
donc systématiquement des cons complique
un peu le raisonnement à des
interprétations de la loi par des
avocats
l'auteur aura d un avocat c'est normal
c'est dans notre droit français et donc
le fait de s'exposer à des
interprétations a contrario risque une
fois plus à l'est à l'envers des
objectifs poursuivis
donc c'est déjà inclus le juge peut le
faire point à la ligne
quelles que soient les circonstances
donc il nous semble dangereux de
rajouter cette précision et pour cette
cette raison la commission a émis un
avis défavorable à vis du gouvernement
madame la ministre
j'entends ce que dit la rapporteure et
les interrogations d'ordre juridique
qu'on peut avoir en veillant toujours à
être efficace et en même temps j'avoue
partager avec la sénatrice gonthier
maurin le constat de ce qui se passe en
réalité et du fait qu'il arrive vraiment
qu'il arrive que une femme ne puisse pas
bénéficier de
fiction du conjoint violent du domicile
parce que à la date de la décision elle
n'était pas elle-même dans le domicile
donc pour être tout à fait franchement
je serais plutôt favorable à cet
amendement
voilà vous vous en déciderez mais je
tiens simplement à profiter de cette
prise de parole pour aussi rappelé que
le gouvernement a créé les conditions
avec la ministre durant charge du
logement en particulier pour augmenter
le nombre de places en centres
d'hébergement spécialisés
je pense que c'est important à rappeler
parce que introduire l'éviction du
conjoint violent du domicile dans la loi
ça ne signifie pas qu'on résout
l'ensemble des questions il y aura
toujours des situations dans lesquelles
les femmes préférons partir de chez elle
il faut que nous continuons à développer
les places d'hébergement voilà mais pour
ce qui est de l'amendement de m gonthier
maurin gilles serait plutôt favorable
ces explications de vote je n'en vois
pas donc je me vois que cet amendement
15 rectifier pour lequel la commission
est défavorable gouvernement est
favorable
ceux qui sont favorables et maintenant
votre but montrer en levant la main
c'est qu'ils sont défavorables il est
donc adopté un amendement 99 rectifié
madame meunier
non madame la ministre
trop souvent les victimes de violence
quittent leur domicile sans pouvoir
emporter leurs effets personnels ni ceux
de leurs enfants le cas échéant cette
situation vient s'ajouter à une
situation de détresse et contribue à les
appauvrir l' ordonnance de protection
doit permettre à ces victimes de se
faire accompagner pour récupérer leurs
effets personnels avec le concours des
forces de l'ordre qui assureront leur
sécurité
il s'agit par cet amendement d'être
cohérent dans la prise en compte de la
gravité de la situation de la femme
victime de violence et d'accompagner
dans un moment risqué pour elle et ainsi
assurer la protection par la loi il
s'agit aussi de donner un
un message aux conjoints violents sur le
fait que leur conjointe a des droits et
que la loi les protège aussi la
commission d'amm club là encore tout en
partageant les préoccupations des
sénateurs qui ont signé cet amendement
la commission a émis un avis défavorable
parce que la loi ne peut pas tout
prévoir le décret ne peut pas tout
prévoir et on s'expose encore une fois à
un effet contraire à celui recherché
ne serait ce que dans la définition des
effets personnels faudrait-il prévoir
dans le décret que le chien le chat le
canari est un effet personnel ou pas
dans quelles conditions il est donc une
fois plus il ne nous semble vraiment pas
opportun d'inscrire dans la loi
par contre qu'on en ait parle
aujourd'hui est une bonne chose parce
que dans le travail pluridisciplinaire
dans la constitution des réseaux qui
vont forcément se constituer avec le
reste du texte et avec les informations
qui va être renforcée
les associations seront bien évidemment
informé les victimes seront mieux
informées qu'elles peuvent se faire
accompagner par les associations les
forces de sécurité pourront aussi
informé des conditions dans lesquelles
la victime peut se faire accompagner et
récupérer ses affaires à eux étant à
proximité immédiate
les forces de l'ordre ne peuvent pas
accompagner les victimes à l'intérieur
ne peuvent être à proximité immédiate et
intervenir aussitôt
donc je pense que c'est plutôt ce
travail là qu'il faut faire que de
s'imaginer qu'on va pouvoir par la loi
prévoir toutes les situations possibles
et inimaginables et finalement ne plus
protéger les victimes
donc avis défavorable lustres oui cette
fois ci je suis sensible moi aussi à
l'effet a contrario que pourrait avoir
une telle précision c'est à dire que a
priori il leur revient naturellement aux
forces de police d'accompagner
précisément une victime qui
chercheraient à reprendre possession de
ses effets et donc je ne crois pas que
ce soit la place ni de la loi ni du
décret que de repréciser cela
et non plus que le détail de ce que ce
sont ses effets personnels
en revanche là où je vous suis donc que
mon avis sera défavorable là où je vous
suis madame meunier c'est que ce type de
précisions nous pouvons les introduire
dans les protocoles d'accord que nous
mettons en place au niveau des
départements que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure pour mieux faire fonctionner les
ordonnances de protection les téléphones
portables grand danger donc vous auriez
un document qui s'appliquerait à tous
les acteurs et qui indiquerait ce type
de procédure à suivre
mais il me semble comme à la rapporteure
que ce n'est pas le lieu de la loi ou du
décret jeu métro voit cet amendement 99
rectifier pour lequel la commission et
les gouvernements sont défavorables ceux
qui sont favorables à cet amendement
veulent réellement 30 devant la main
ceux qui y sont défavorables
attendez ceux qui sont défavorables
c'est nous qui les rejeter un moment 43
rectifié monsieur courteau oui monsieur
le président afin de permettre au juge
aux affaires familiales de démontrer la
réalité des violences
le présent amendement offre aux juges
aux affaires familiales la possibilité
de demander au procureur de la
république de diligenter une enquête
rapide à l'effet de vérifier la
situation matérielle familiales et
sociales de la partie défenderesse ainsi
qu'une enquête sur sa personnalité
cette enquête apportera des éléments
complémentaires et peut-être évitera de
passer à côté d'une situation que j'ai
qualifiée tout à l'heure de préoccupante
eux-mêmes d'alarmante merci à vis de la
commission
cet événement déjà satisfait par les
application des articles l 143 et
suivants du code de procédure civile et
en plus relève du domaine réglementaire
donc avis défavorable
madame le ministre
oui monsieur le sénateur c'est vrai que
le code prévoit déjà que le juge informe
le procureur de la république des
requêtes qu'il a reçus en vue de
prononcer une ordonnance de protection
et il leur revient ensuite au parc et
d'apprécier l'effet de diligenter une
enquête si les faits qui sont portés à
sa connaissance justifie des poursuites
pénales
l' ordonnance de protection je le redis
est une mesure civile et la décision du
juge repose sur des éléments produits
devant lui par les parties et débattu de
manière contradictoire c'est une mesure
qui doit être rendue dans l'urgence est
donc le fait de procéder à l' enquête
que vous évoquez risquerait de retarder
même de dénaturer le dispositif de l'
ordonnance de protection donc je dis
suis défavorable je vous remercie aussi
où étaient indécis bon bon la reporter
la ministre on vit vraiment rassuré et
je vais le retirer un amendement en 33 c
vous madame plus qu'ammann qui oui
lorsqu'on fait des faits de violences
conjugales sont jugés
le juge peut ordonner un suivi
socio-judiciaire du conjoint violent
avec injonction de soins s'il considère
que cela est nécessaire
dans les faits les problèmes de violence
conjugale sont souvent amplifiés franck
nous savons et nous l'avons d'ailleurs
décrit les uns les autres par des
problèmes sociaux parfois psychologique
plus graves
cet amendement vise donc à permettre au
juge qui délivre une ordonnance de
protection d'ordonner également une
prise en charge sanitaire social
psychologique de l'auteur des violences
afin d'éviter la récidive qui n'est que
trop courante dans ce genre de situation
les auteurs nous pensons à travers
également cet amendement que les auteurs
de violences ont besoin d'un
accompagnement et d'une prise en charge
particulière qu'il s'agit est ce qu'il
s'agisse d'ailleurs d'une thérapie d'un
travail de réinsertion avec à chaque
fois qu un objectif de leur permettre de
sortir de leurs arbitres de leurs
habitudes de violence et de la
commission
cette proposition est à la limite des
compétences du juge civil néanmoins la
commissure des lois a émis un avis
favorable dans la mesure où le
contradictoire a été respectée beau
monde de l' ordonnance de protection et
dans la mesure où il nous semble que ça
ne peut être qu'un plus pour la victime
et pour la protection des victimes
puisque ce genre de dispositif aider à
éviter la récidive donc avis favorable
merci le gouvernement madame le ministre
d'abord vous avez raison madame la
sénatrice luc hermann de mettre l'accent
sur la prise en charge des auteurs de
violences conjugales
c'est évidemment une condition
essentielle pour la prévention de la
récidive et nous l'avons fait également
dans le projet de loi nous y reviendrons
la prise en charge que vous proposez
d'abord elles figurent déjà parmi les
mesures alternatives aux poursuites qui
sont énumérées à l'article 41 du code de
procédure pénale ou le parquet une fois
qu'il est informé des faits portés à la
connaissance du juge dans le cadre de l'
ordonnance de protection peut
parfaitement prendre une telle mesure
ce sont ses prérogatives cela étant l'
ordonnance de protection c'est une
mesure civile provisoire qui repose sur
la vraisemblance des faits uniquement et
donc qu'il ne peut pas être assimilée
nous semble-t-il à une mesure pénale qui
serait prise par le procureur dans le
cadre de sa libre appréciation de
l'opportunité des poursuites
et donc qui risquerait là encore des
traces et contre-productive pour
l'efficacité et la rapidité de l'
ordonnance de protection donc nous y
serons défavorable merci explications de
vote
je n'en vois pas que je me trouve à
seulement 233 qui a reçu un avis
favorable de la commission est
défavorable du gouvernement ceux qui
sont favorables amendement veulent bien
levé la main qui sont favorables
s'ils voulaient bien levé la main
réellement ceux qui sont favorables
amendement pour qu'on puisse compter
j'ai pas demandé les deux il me suffit
merci ceux qui sont défavorables
il est adopté un article se suicident
trois amendements discussion commune
l'amendement numéro 100 rectifier dans
la menier mais monsieur le président
madame la ministre il s'agit d'étendre
la mesure de protection à tous les cas
de violence subie par les femmes
les viols les violences sexuelles les
violences intrafamiliales les violences
conjugales
le mariage forcé les mutilations
génitales les violences envers les
femmes sont des violences particulières
dans leurs mécanismes et du fait de la
proximité avec les auteurs de ces
violences dans la plupart des cas en
effet le mécanisme d'emprise et de peurs
auxquelles sont soumises les victimes
sont identiques dans tous les cas de
violence et nécessitent souvent une mise
en sécurité particulièrement dans la
période où a lieu a eu lieu la
dénonciation des faits de violences
subies par un proche ce qui est un cas
très fréquent
donc nous devons être cohérents une fois
de plus à accompagner concrètement les
victimes qui prennent des risques
personnels à sortir de l'emprise et
add-on dénoncer leur agresseur
il est important de permettre à
l'ensemble des femmes victimes et qui se
sentent menacés de bénéficier d'une
mesure de protection
on l'a entendu souvent au moment des
audiences des associations merci
amendement 112,9 fructifier vous madame
laborde
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mais chers collègues depuis la
loi du 9 juillet 2010 le juge des
affaires familiales peut délivrer une
ordonnance de protection dans les cas de
menace de mariage forcé notre amendement
propose d'étendre cette mesure d'urgence
au cas de mutilations sexuelles
les violences coutumières comme le
mariage forcé mais aussi les mutilations
sexuelles sont des formes de violences
totalement inacceptables dans notre pays
et il est de notre responsabilité de
protéger ses victimes de violence
insupportable
nous savons bien que les victimes de
mutilations sexuelles sont souvent des
enfants
que le juge compétent et dans ce cas le
juge des enfants et qu'il dispose de
pouvoirs extrêmement large
mais les mutilations génitales féminines
concerne aussi des femmes adultes qui
les subissent au moment de leur mariage
au cours de leur grossesse ou à la suite
du premier accouchement nous ne pouvons
pas les ignorer ces femmes se sentant
menacé de mutilations sexuelles doivent
pouvoir être protégés avant même le
dépôt de plainte
je vous remercie merci un moment tu 134
rectifié même plus qu'ammann oui je
crois que je suis déjà intervenu sur
cette question dans l'intervention sur
article donc gérer rapidement
je crois que ça rejoint de toute façon
ce qui a été dit l'objectif d'étendre
cette ordonnance de protection victimes
de viols d'agressions sexuelles de
harcèlement sexuel dans les cas où les
pères les victimes seraient en situation
de danger pardon est bien de donner
accès à ses victimes à cette ordonnance
de protection ce qui leur permettrait de
se sentir plus en sécurité dans la tente
du jugement
face à un agresseur qu'elles sont
parfois forcés de croiser
quotidiennement que ce soit dans leur
entourage proche madame me le disait que
ce soit aussi dans sur leur lieu de vie
que ce soit aussi sur le lieu de travail
il nous semble en tout cas que cela
pourrait permettre une réelle protection
de ses victimes à la fois aussi pour que
les plaintes puisse être déposée et dans
la tente du jugement a vu de la
commission se trouvait mandement 29 sur
ces trois amendements l'avis de la
commission était le même bien évidemment
nous partageons ce qui a été exprimé sur
le caractère totalement inédit il
acceptable pardon de ses de ces faits de
violence inouïe néanmoins et peut-être
même justement il ne faut pas confondre
un dispositif civile avec un dispositif
pénal et s'est fait la relève vraiment
du pénal directement et pas d'un
dispositif civils d'urgence
dispositif pénal qui peut aller jusqu'à
la mise en détention provisoire de
l'auteur donc pour ces raisons nous
avons émis un avis défavorable
merci le gouvernement madame le ministre
oui monsieur président avant de répondre
à ces trois amendements je voudrais
revenir un instant sur celui qui a été
adoptée précédemment je vais pas vous
demander de voter évidemment il s'agit
pas de cela mais je voudrais quand même
que vous soyez bien conscient d'une
chose c'est que le dispositif même de
l'ordonance de protection mesure civile
et non pénale est précieux et fragile et
que tout ce que nous lui ajoute on de
nature quasi pénale ou de règles
automatiques lui porte préjudice ce
dispositif n'a pas été examiné jusqu'à
présent par le conseil constitutionnel
il n'a pas fait l'objet d'une qpc rien
exclu qu'il le fasse à l'avenir et donc
je ne voudrais pas que le dispositif
tombe parce que nous avons cherché à
être trop généreux entendez moi bien
c'est pour cette raison que je ne suis
pas d'accord avec certaines des
propositions qui ont été faites jusqu'à
présent et je ne serais pas d'accord non
plus avec ses trois amendements qui nous
ont été présentés pour les raisons que
qu'a rappelé madame claire bien sûr à
savoir que qu'il s'agisse du viol ou des
mutilations sexuelles on est face à des
crimes qui doivent être traités comme
tels les affaires criminelles doivent
être traitées devant les assises
et donc nous ne pouvons pas nous même
envoyé un signal de
sous qualification en quelque sorte de
ces affaires je redis que l' ordonnance
de protection est une procédure civile
qui s'adresse à des victimes qui ne
souhaite pas poursuivre l'auteur pour
des raisons liées notamment à la
promiscuité familiales etc etc on peut
très bien comprendre il ne faut pas
l'élargir outre mesure en revanche là où
je serais favorable c'est aux
dispositions qui pourraient être
proposées pour que des mesures de
protection comme le téléphone portable
grand danger par exemple soit étendue au
delà des violences conjugales aux
victimes de viol donc ça c'est un sujet
encore différent mais sur les trois
amendements qui viennent d'être déposés
avis défavorable donc je me trouve voit
le moment faut rectifier des
explications de vote
monsieur longuet pardon monsieur le
président madame le ministre mes chers
collègues moi je suis très sensible à
l'argumentation de madame le ministre
nous avons besoin de pouvoir mettre fin
à des situations inacceptables en
restant dans l'ordre civil pour éviter
de transformer ce qui est un conflit en
une tragédie et j'attire votre attention
sur le fait que l' ordonnance civile
doit pouvoir fonctionner aisément être
brandie comme non seulement comme une
menace mais mise en oeuvre alors que
l'action pénale risque de créer une
situation irréversible ce que ne
souhaitent pas nécessairement le
conjoint qui par ailleurs souhaitent une
protection jeu vraiment je demande à mes
amis de bien vouloir suivre le
gouvernement sur ce point
merci haute explication ne vois je ne
vois pas donc le sens rectifié avis
défavorable de la commission défavorable
du gouvernement ceux qui sont favorables
d'amendements veulent bien levez la main
ceux qui sont défavorables
ceux qui sont défavorables faut lever la
main parce que bien n'est pas adopté le
119 rectifié avis défavorable de la
commission défavorable du gouvernement
ceux qui sont favorables bien levez la
main ceux qui sont défavorables
il n'est pas d'adopter le 134 rectifier
retirée je suis saisi d'un amendement
samba rectifié doit être madame laborde
je vais bien vu monsieur président
encore aujourd'hui de nombreuses
familles renvoient leurs enfants à
l'étranger contre leur gré pour y être
mariées de force
lorsqu'une jeune femme se sent menacées
de mariage forcé
le juge aux affaires familiales que
délivrer une ordonnance de protection et
prévoir notamment l'interdiction de
sortie du territoire français temporaire
de la personne menacée
il s'agit de situations dramatiques et
nécessite que l'on agisse rapidement
or nous savons pertinemment que les
délais de délivrance de l'ordonance sont
beaucoup trop longs
vingt-six jours en moyenne selon le
conseil national de l'aide aux victimes
certes madame la ministre vous avez
souhaité que l' ordonnance de protection
soient désormais délivrés dans les
meilleurs délais pour autant dans le cas
de mariages forcés
surtout lorsqu'ils ont lieu à l'étranger
il serait souhaitable que l' ordonnance
de protection soit délivré
automatiquement dès qu'une jeune femme
se sent menacées de mariage forcé s'ils
avaient de la commission la commission a
un peu débattu autour de cet amendement
parce qu'effectivement ça rend une
un prononcé des ordonnances de
protection automatique
cependant on est dans un cas assez
particulier où la menace de mariage
forcé est avéré c'est pas ce sens mais
la victime a démontré la menace de
mariage forcé donc effectivement là il
ya réellement urgence à délivrer leur
donnant de protection donc c'est du fait
de cette petite nuance que la commission
a émis un avis favorable mais avec
toujours ses réticences sur
l'automaticité malgré tout l'avis du
gouvernement la ministre
d'abord je comprends très bien madame la
sénatrice laborde votre souhait que le
prononcé de l'ordonnancé de protection
pour les cas de menace de mariage forcé
soit plus fréquents c'est vrai qu'on ne
peut que déplorer parce que je rappelle
que c'est possible aujourd'hui mais on
ne peut que déplorer le faible nombre de
ces ordonnances prononcées
nous avons décidé de nous attaquer à ce
sujet en travaillant notamment avec le
ministère en charge des français de
l'étranger puisque c'est souvent des
victimes amenées à l'étranger pour
procéder à ces mariages donc en
procédant à une meilleure information
des françaises des françaises et des
français qui sont dans cette situation
un meilleur accompagnement grâce à nos
consulats aussi et puis nous avons par
ailleurs renforcer les sanctions qui
pèsent sur tout ce qui tourne autour du
mariage forcé y compris l'incitation
faite à opérer un mariage forcé on en a
discuté ici à quelques mois pour
l'amendement que vous proposez
aujourd'hui je j'estime aussi que
l'automaticité imposé va être au fond
nuisible à une individualisation des
réponses que doit apporter le juge aux
situations des victimes donc j'y serais
défavorable
merci l'explication de vote je ne vois
pas donc je m envoie cet amendement s'en
va rectifier pour lequel je rappelle la
commission favorable gouvernement est
défavorable ceux qui sont favorables
d'amendements veulent bien levez la main
ceux qui sont favorables
c'est qu'ils sont défavorables il est
adopté
je suis donc mettre aux voix l'article 7
ceux qui sont favorables à cet article 7
va lever la main ceux qui sont
défavorables
l'article 7 est adopté article 8 je suis
saisie de quatre amendements discussion
commune l'article 16 rectifié madame
gonthier maurin
merci monsieur le président madame
ministre mes chers collègues la
médiation pénale est une des mesures
alternatives aux poursuites que peut
prendre le procureur de la république
sur le fondement de l'article 41 tirs et
1 du code de procédure pénale elle est
particulièrement inapte hop inappropriée
dans les situations de violence
conjugale car elle revient à mettre face
à face dans une situation faussement
égalitaire l'auteur des violences et la
victime au risque de contribuer au
renforcement des phénomène d'emprise
comme le rappelle régulièrement les
associations de défense des femmes la
loi du 9 juillet 2010 en a réduit le
champ d'application en introduisant une
présomption de non consentement à la
médiation pénale pour les personnes
bénéficiant d'une ordonnance de
protection
le projet de loi va plus loin en
subordonnant la médiation pénale à la
demande expresse de la victime dans les
situations de violence au sein du couple
la commission des lois propose d'en
restreindre encore le champ en
l'interdisant en cas de récidive ce
n'est pas assez puisque l'on s'accordent
sur l'immigration de cette procédure en
cas de violence conjugale
tirons-en toutes les conséquences et
interdisant purement et simplement tout
recours à la médiation pénale dans ce
type de situation tel est l'objet du
présent amendement qui apporte une
traduction législative à la
recommandation numéro 22 adoptée par la
délégation aux droits des femmes
merci amendement 113 rectifier mais
madame laborde
actuellement lorsque le procureur de la
république a connaissance de faits de
violences conjugales il peut avant de
prendre une décision
faire procéder à une mission de
médiation entre l'auteur des faits et la
victime
la médiation a pour but de parvenir à
une issue accepté par les deux parties
certes l'article 8 propose d'encadrer
davantage les conditions dans lesquelles
les parquets pourront recourir à la
médiation pénale en cas de violences au
sein d'un couple
elle ne sera notamment possible qu'à la
demande de la victime
par ailleurs la commission des lois a
précisé qu'il ne pourrait procéder à de
nouvelles médiations en cas de
réitération des violences pour autant je
pense qu'il n'est pas souhaitable
d'autoriser la médiation pénale dans les
cas de violence conjugale
nous le savons bien les violences au
sein d'un couple traduisent la plupart
du temps un rapport de force entre
l'auteur des faits la victime
elles ont un effet destructeur pour les
victimes qui se trouvent souvent sous
l'emprise de leur conjoint il n'est pas
possible dans ces conditions de place
c'est l'auteur des violences et sa
victime dans une situation faussement
égalitaire je vous remercie
voilà vous avez pu suivre une partie de
l'examen du projet de loi sur l'égalité
femmes hommes
tout de suite on retrouve delphine
girard pour 24,1 sénat